Hello, everyone. This is Dr. Kelly Hall-Derman. Welcome to our weekly Wednesday Zoom call.
So I am going to be your host today. Dr. Connors is
away, and he asked me to step in today and do a presentation on the NERP2 pathway and self-forafane.
So it's going to be really exciting. This is a really, really cool nutrient.
This has a ton of research behind it, and the research really knocked our socks off and got us thinking.
So we wanted to do a Zoom call on this particular nutrient. So before we get started,
a Zoom question came in yesterday, and it's a really great question, and it is,
can you describe the pros and cons of surgery and biopsies when you have cancer?
And I discuss this with the staff, and we think that this is such a great question
that we want to do an additional piece on it and have its own time devoted to this question
because it may be one that a lot of people have, and we should actually spend some time on.
So we are on the case. We are going to get a presentation or even maybe next week's Zoom call
devoted to this question of describing the pros and cons of surgeries and biopsies when you have
cancer. So stay tuned for that. So over here, I have a chat section, so if anyone's having problems
hearing me or if you have any questions that can't wait to the end, you can definitely chat me over here,
and I can answer those questions. But this presentation is going to be pretty short and sweet
into the point, and then I'm going to open it up for some additional questions on this.
So let me make this nice and big. Okay, so the Nerf 2 pathway in Sulforofane, an important pathway
in cancer and its potent inducer. So the Nerf 2 pathway is getting really popular these days,
and it has a lot of implications, not only in anti-aging, but definitely in cancer. It's one of
the most important biological pathways in the human body. It has importance in, like I said,
cancer-aging inflammation and detoxification. So it's so cool that it's been called the pathway
of the fountain of youth, the cancer-protecting pathway, and the master detox pathway. So again,
just a ton of research is being poured into this pathway. And when we talk about pathways,
we're talking about biochemical biological reactions that are happening on a second-by-second
basis, and basically every single one of your cells. And we know from listening to Dr.
Conner's talk about pathways and biochemistry and genetics, that genetics does play an important role
in how well those pathways work. And we are always looking at these pathways in terms of cancer.
And it's really exciting news that I wanted to present to you that we are going to be doing,
teaming up with the Neutrogenetic Research Institute. And we're going to be doing some research
ourselves on genetics and cancer. So we're going to be digging even deeper. But this pathway,
the Nerf2 pathway, is super important in cancer. So if you've had your genetics done, we've already
taken a look at this pathway. So what is this Nerf2 pathway? It's basically a pathway that ensures
that you are activating your survival genes, the genes that keep us alive. Basically, we're looking
at this pathway from an importance of detoxification in this toxic world. And we're looking at this pathway
and protecting us from oxidative stress. And oxidative stress is basically the imbalance between
free radical production from a zillion different things and our antioxidant production. So I like this
pathway. I like this depiction right here. So anything that you see in green is the gene. And if we've
listened to Dr. Connors, we know all about what genes are. They're instructions to make proteins
and enzymes. And what's important in this particular depiction is that we have this big,
whopping red pink area of oxidative stress. So the NFE2L2 is the gene that is responsible for,
let's just say, activating the Nerf2 pathway, or making the Nerf2 pathway, the enzymes that push
this. So when our body senses the oxidative stress, it will, in act, it'll say, hey, okay, the Nerf2,
the NFE2L2, we'll wake up and turn on. And it's actually a transcription factor, which is kind of
high level biochemistry. But what it does is it goes down to the DNA. And it tells the DNA, hey,
we got some problems here. Our house is on fire. We need to call in the fire department. We need to
get some antioxidants going. So the Nerf2L2 will interact with that antioxidant response element.
And that's just on your DNA. And again, it's just telling it, okay, we got problems, we have to put
out the fire. So what that does is activate glutathione transcription. So it's almost like the Nerf2
pathways is the master regulator for the master detoxer. So it says, okay, let's speed up our production
of glutathione. And that, again, is so important in detoxification and keeping our cells in our
body as healthy. And it also activates another pathway over here on the left. It activates the NQO1
pathway. And that is detoxification. So our whole point of this is that we have oxidative stress.
And we need to detox out. So pretty, that's simplistic terms. But that's where the Nerf2 pathway.
And the environment we live in, it is very, very important that our Nerf2 pathway is optimized.
Nerf2 has its implications specifically in tumor suppressor protein and glutathione. So
interestingly, it interacts with other important cell regulators such as that tumor suppressor protein
53 and nuclear factor capobata. So NF capobata. And those are really important in, in cancer. And it's
called this pathway has been called the guardian of health because it can protect against many age-related
diseases. And it also activates what we said on the last slide. It activates that glutamate, glutamate
cystine ligase, which is involved in glutathione synthesis. So keeping this pathway going at everyone
of yourself super important. So luckily, God gave us a wonderful compound that super regulates,
super up regulates the NRF, the Nerf2 pathway. And that is called isothyl cyanate. And what that
does is just goes in and just turns that puppy on. So it is cranking out all kinds of
antioxidants and making sure that DNA is protected, making sure there's a balance between
the free radicals are being scavenged by the antioxidants. So isothyl cyanate is the name of that.
That compound is found in cruciferous vegetables. So thank you, God. And it's most, it's most, the greatest
amount is found in broccoli sprouts, cauliflower, cabbage and kale. So broccoli sprouts, there's the number
one most potent. And you can see here there's a picture of some broccoli sprouts. And a typical
quart jar of broccoli sprouts, it contains around 90 to 120 milligrams of the active form of the
isothyl cyanate. And the active form is actually called sulforophane. So that's that fancy name of
the whole presentation is sulforophane. And that's the compound. So really, interestingly,
again, is that the enzyme that converts isothyl cyanate to sulforophane. It's activated by chewing
and crushing, but it's inactivated by boiling and cooking. So I eat a lot of broccoli. And before
I started doing the research, I used to steam my broccoli. Now I've decided that I probably should
implement in a little bit more of the raw stuff because I'm pretty much inactivating the potent
NRF2 pathway inducer. So it's all about balance though. And again, so if you want to make broccoli
sprouts, you're going to get about 90 to 120 milligrams of sulforophane. So sulforophane has anti-cancer
properties. And the number one, and we're going to go through these. So number one is that it prevents
deactivation of phase one biotransformation enzymes. So what those enzymes are responsible from doing is
taking pro carcinogens into carcinogens. So you can see how deactivating this would not be a good
thing that we'd want this definitely to be working. And the number two thing that it does it can
activate phase two detoxification enzymes. And we definitely want those working in cancer. We want
them working. And even a perfectly young child, we want those working really well. It has increased
expression in that NQ-O1 gene. And that, again, translates down to really good detoxification.
And it prevents the degradation of the tumor suppressor protein P53. So I thought it was super
interesting because the literature says that over 50% of adult cancers have a broken or mutated
P53. So looking at sulforophane and cancer patients is extremely important. And we're going to take a
look at a little bit of the research in a second here. And lastly, sulforophane can prevent DNA
adducts, which is a type of DNA damage known to lead to cancer. DNA adducts are very prevalent in
people with a history of smoking. So I'm going to show you some studies are going to knock your socks off too.
Okay, so we all know that our veggies are good for us. And that, you know, our parents probably told us
each of veggies a million times. But when you're looking at the research, it would say the same thing.
That there's a decreased cancer risk in those who consume healthy amounts of cruciferous vegetables
on a regular basis. You can look that up and take that one to the bank. Definitely, there are a lot
of studies not just in cancer, but a lot of other diseases too that really benefit from those who
just had always been consuming these cruciferous vegetables. So in 2010 a study was done on smokers who
consumed 4.5 servings of raw cruciferous vegetables per month. And they were shown to have a 55% reduction
in lung cancer, 55% and that's not a whole lot of servings there. So definitely in talking about those
DNA adducts and how sulforophane can really help lessen the damage of that. That's super cool.
The next one. So multiple studies have shown that women who have consumed cruciferous
vegetables at least once a week had between a 17 and 50% reduction in breast cancer for those
consuming it every day. So I think this was from a meta analysis. So a big study that looked at
other little studies. So it has a lot of power to it. The next one in a study where men with prostate
were giving 60 milligrams of sulforophane daily. And that's approximately 140 grams of fresh
broccoli sprouts. And again, that's about that quart. If you did your own broccoli sprouts, if you grew
your own broccoli sprouts, that's somewhere about half of that would give you that amount of sulforophane.
But the results showed a slowing of the doubling rate of PSA by 80% compared to placebo. It's like,
wow, okay. So this is a big deal. And these are just a couple of the studies that I pulled.
There's a lot more. But I really thought these were really good. And then I'm finally a study
in those with bladder cancer demonstrate that consuming four servings of raw cruciferous vegetables
per month decreased bladder cancer mortality by 57%. Compared with those who only consumed one serving.
We're not looking at a ton of consumption either. With these studies, I was looking at,
well, is this realistic? Are they feeding? They did a lot of animal studies as well.
And I'm looking at, well, what was the surveys? They basically have to eat seven pounds of the
cruciferous vegetables per day. And really, they didn't. It was a modest amount. And definitely
something that's doable. But what's even cooler is that the Connors Clinic have come out with their
own formulation. And it is called Brocco Clear. It contains 60 milligrams per cap of the cell
fluorophane. And that is a lot. That's actually the most that there is on the market at this point.
So it's very, very potent. It's easier than sprouting your own broccoli sprouts. But I'm not against that.
I think that's fine if you want to do that. And we've been having people start on this. And I just
recently started on it as well. We're just really excited because look at all the the research that
is behind it. And not only is there research on cancer guys, there's research on
so, fluorophane and depression and anxiety. So, fluorophane and hormonal regulations. So,
fluorophane and ADHD and other brain neurological conditions. It's just, it's exploding. So the
the nerve two pathway research is exploding. And so is the cell fluorophane. And these two go
together really well. And even in those people who have no genetic defects in the nerve two pathway,
I really believe that the environment we live in, why wouldn't we want to upregulate this pathway?
It seems that even in those who don't have anything going on per se, that this would be a really nice
addition. And so, what we also come up with because we just we can't stop ourselves here. We just
we just have to do better and and learn more and figure things out to to to help you guys and to
help to help optimize what we're doing here. So we came up with a delivery system. So a new delivery
system where we're looking at using the portal cable anastomosis system. And I'm actually writing
an article for cancer tutor right now on this pathway. It's so it's an asthmosis and it's basically
the delivery system is using your rectal mucosa instead of oral. And now don't hang up on me
too soon now. So what we're looking at is doing just a more of a retention, not a not an anema
per se. And we're using different equipment with it because the rectal mucosa. First of all, when we're
when we're in this environment where our food is contaminated and the you know the things that we eat
are our gut. It takes a beating and the absorption it sometimes it's not as good as we want it
and we know that our gut is the foundation of health. So we really want to have we want we obviously
we always pay attention to that. So looking at the rectal mucosa it has ability to absorb some of
these nutrients and it can actually in this paper that I'm putting out of this article it actually
has a higher bioavailability compared to oral when you're looking at delivery of this. And it
also when you're using the rectal route you're bypassing two thirds of the first pass metabolism
as the rectum's venous drainage is two thirds systemic and one third hepatic. So basically what
that means is that the substance and nutrient will reach the circulatory system with significantly less
alteration and in greater concentrations. So that's really cool because we really want you know not
only are we looking at the delivery we're looking at are they absorbing are you absorbing it is it
getting to where it needs to go. So a new delivery system be on the lookout we're going to be testing
this and and looking at putting some of our patients on this instead. So that concludes the actual
presentation the PowerPoint. So I'm going to open it up for questions. I'm going to unmute everybody.
Okay so if anyone has a question why don't we just go for it and we'll just have a dialogue
for the new delivery system. If somebody had a colostomy does that mean it wouldn't work. No actually
it would work really well. So we're looking at using rectal catheters and people already have those
in place and having people who have have different sorts of catheters feeding tubes we're looking at.
So that would actually be that would be appropriate. Good question. And just I don't know if you'd know
but what about a coffee animus does a coffee anima depend on the colon being attached like
that's really good question. I believe a coffee anima the effectiveness is through the rectal mucosa.
So I would think that it would be I don't think I don't think you'd get this response. That's what I would
I would think you would have to use the rectal mucosa to get into that like portal system. So
we can check with Dr. Connors too. Dr. Kelly I'm assuming that if you use this you would do your coffee
anima first. Correct absolutely. And so that's a really good point too is that if you're going to be
doing a coupling with the coffee anima you want to do that first and make sure it flushes out and
this is going to be more of a very small retention lake where you're not necessarily even going to
notice anything coming back out per se. We wanted it a very small amount so that you're not causing
when the when the rectum has that dilutation it immediately will want to defecate so basically we're
trying to keep it to a minimum. Are you saying using the rectal mucosa system it's going to be better
even than taking the bottle cleaner capsules is that what you're saying? You know the literature so I'm
we're looking up in the literature and it's showing that there's a higher bioavailability as well as
we're again we're bypassing that first pass so when you're taking something via the gut so orally
it has to go through it has to basically be processed and it has to check out with all your immune
cells that line the gut in that the stomach area and the small intestine area and so we're looking at
if the delivery is so much better in the rectum we're looking at okay well which one are we going
to get better absorption with and it's looking like it's it's not a hard fast rule by any means we can
still definitely take orally the the broccoli clear and get a really good effect we're just looking at
couldn't we do it better again can we do it more efficiently? So would you as a case by case basis look
at our profile and decide whether it's it's something a therapy that you recommend for us?
Yes or is it just okay? Yes and then you would be looking down through our genetic workup
making those recommendations. Yeah absolutely and looking through the Nerf 2 and making sure that
that that's optimized and seeing if you have a predisposition for that pathway not to work that would
be an important addition to it I I don't personally after doing research in this for a couple of
weeks I don't see any downsides per se to using it I I'm a minimalist I don't like to use a ton of
supplements but I'm seeing so much robust scientific research behind this that I'm it's hard for me to
look at a even perfect a person with perfect the Nerf 2 pathway genes let's just say they have perfect
taxification it really if they'd say Dr. Holmer is this something that I shouldn't take I would not say
no I would definitely think that then you just look at the studies or just encourage you're just
knowing that these cruciferous vegetables and how to eat them raw or doing broccoli sprouts just kind
of looking at that is it's extremely helpful you know you don't have to go full blown doing the
the retention enemas with this but we're just looking at how can we do this better and how can we
how can we facilitate this because we know that cell forafanes activation if if you take cell
forafane orally it couldn't be there was a study done where you can assay a breast tumor cell I believe
and it had the cell forafane in it and hour later so and we're looking at okay well what would be
the difference what is the the positives and the negatives to this type of delivery so it's it's
again it's not a one size fits all but cell forafane and then but self might be that one size
fits everyone because of the the studies what if you had leaky gut would your auto would it be
causing autoimmune disease against it or anything like that so the leaky gut is the situation where
I definitely would want to be aggressive and use the rectal veins I'd want to use the rectal
administration because I don't want to chance it that they're not absorbing and I'm going to
publish on the Facebook page probably in the next two days my article my original article on the novel
nutraceutical delivery system that I'm talking about and it does talk about that in that we have to
mean the gut is a foundation of health a lot of people who who have cancer unfortunately have
gut issues too you know we just don't walk around with cancer we have other issues as well like
high cholesterol and you know hypertension so if you have that that would make make me more inclined
to say hey let's do this rectally if that if that makes sense can you overdo I grow broccoli sprouts I
grow kale either eat it in salads or smoothies and I also take NRF2 accelerator can you get too much
of this I think that you can get too much of it I think that the that zone if you listen to my my
talk on the the Goldilocks area under the bell curve or that's where your body wants to be it's
called your hermetic zone and basically there's a hermetic zone for everything for the mono zinc in
your body for the amount of glutathione in your body so for so for a fein and for let's say the sulfur
groups there's probably there's a there's a window there's a Goldilocks zone it's probably pretty wide
enough could you overdose on it I I suppose I really wouldn't I would gauge yourself so
it let's say that you're doing what you're doing and then you add in let's say you're going to add in
one oral brocco clear per day and you notice something that could be your body signaling you that
hey I had enough okay now do you have product to use in the enema now we do okay so that's it's a
liquid or yeah so it's a suspension so basically you just mix it yourself and you can draw it up
and then you can just reuse the drying syringe you can use but you can't really can't reuse the
tubing per se so we're trying to look at the most environmentally friendly way of
of doing this and from that standpoint we're kind of tinkering around with a couple different we're in
the beta testing stages of the actual equipment and delivery but you could use basically anything
really for the delivery so is there an applicator on the end of that tube where we just missing part of
the picture um this one right here the one I just highlighted we still see in my screen so no so
that that'll just that'll just be inserted right up into the rack down it's very small it's extremely small
um and then you can just push the syringe up and it's flexible so it shouldn't cause any damage or
anything if you're sensitive to sulfur does this relate it to the transpiration pathway also or not
so that's a really good question too so I so looking at the transpiration pathway
it's really in its infancy on looking at if you have CBS up really a up regulation or down regulation
and so what I really tend to do with people is I do trial and error we know the positive effects
of the sulfur of pain we know that there's people like myself I there's a threshold of sulfur
that my body can handle but that's usually in the form of anacetyl cysteine or other things um like
if you take a lot of glutathione so I that's a really good question and what I would say is
again it's a trial and error you may take this and have let's say you're you have sulfur issues
if you take this but your body needs it so badly to up-regulate that pathway that it is just blowing
through it's just chewing through it and you don't even notice if that makes sense because you're
utilizing it as opposed to the other forms of sulfur usually go down the trans sulfuration pathway
in order to make the end product glutathione so this is kind of a different back door-ish approach
where we remember on that on this depiction right here so the NRF2 pathway so we're stimulating it
and then we're making the glutathione on our own which is I really highly favor
pushing the pathway instead of giving the end product it just seems more of a godly way of doing
things is to just help just help propagate the pathway that god already gave us instead of giving
the end point so again I I would rather have someone taking the sulfur of pain pushing this pathway
doing this all naturally than loading up on a bunch of glutathione or anacetyl cysteine so we I
you can always post questions specific ones on the Facebook page if you have a question like okay
I'm gonna try this or I tried this I can definitely give you some feedback with that great question though
so if you have like from allergies to the lily family the onions and the garlic and garlic and all
those this would be a way a different way pathway to go through yep you could give it a try and see
if it's if if it I mean you kind of get an idea of when you're sulfur overloaded there's also test
strips that I employ I use them they're on Amazon you can get sulfur test strips to see if your
sulfates and your sulfates are high so you know if you start taking this and you notice you're
having a symptom but you check those and you're fine it could be for something else so I don't I don't
necessarily like to shoot in the dark so I like a lot of testing strips like that now I will tell you
I am extremely sensitive to sulfur things I have to limit them I started taking 120 milligrams
of the sulfur of pain and I've yet to have any problems because I really think that like I said I
think the body is doing with it what it needs to do and it's chewing through it so that it's not
building up does that make sense okay how do you test use test strips how do you use those you just
urinate on them first morning urine okay thank you I can post a link to to those test strips on
Facebook page okay great questions you guys this is a little kind of side off the subject but like
when I keep hearing about anti accidents like I thought oxygen is good for your body so what is it
about accidents that you know is negative when it has acts acts in it is an oxygen so so anti-oxidants
are are good so free radicals which are generated from the toxins environment free radicals are
generated just normal process of our bodies functions so those when that free radical like it goes
around the body and it hurts stuff like it it runs into the cell membrane and it damages the
cell membrane and it runs into your DNA and it damages your DNA so what an anti-oxidant does is it
comes in and it donates an electron so then the free radical is neutralized so then it can no longer
cause damage if that does that make sense yeah but I mean a free radical I'm trying to picture
what it actually is is it so it's just I would say it's something that does cellular damage so it's
just a just think of it as a substance that goes around the body and oh it's like it's like a liquid
or like I mean you know what kind of form does it take um probably more if you think of it like a
biochemical compound like if you think of like glutathione how it has that biochemical structure
or like vitamin C you know how they have like those it's like a ring and it's got some
carbons and hydrogens and things like that like it just has this it just has this just free radical
it's the free definition that free radical is that it's just reactive it's like explosive it's like
going around and knocking things on and everything it touches it's hurting so then the anti-oxidant
comes in and neutralizes it it hands them in another electron because two electrons together do
not cause damage so it's um it's not really a liquid per se but more of like a compound in
your cells so your body kind of produces that as a result of tax it's like a product yeah and it's
actually free radicals are a byproduct of just being alive just breathing and eating food so in some
of the free radicals our bodies produce actually protect us from pathogens so we it's it's all
about balance it really is it's not like we want to eradicate every free radical in our body and
it's not like we want to dump our indoor body of ton of antioxidants we want a really nice balance
any other questions order this online then you yes you can order it online there's instructions on the
uh pass that are kept on how to use that there will be yes definitely there will be instructions with
that will mail a sheet out to and how to deliver it and then we're looking at you know if you obviously
if you have colon cancers or things that are in the localized area it's going to be even more
appropriate or if you have again leaky gut so if you're not sure just post on Facebook page and we can
answer that for you and again I I've been using the rectal form because I don't want to take a
chance I want it to be I want it to be delivered and I don't want any I don't want my gut getting in the
way of that so that's what I do so I take it this is okay to experiment with yeah absolutely and
a side side effect of the experimentation could be that you're happier and your hair grows
okay so we're safe in experimenting with it yeah yeah I don't think so I don't want you taking the
whole bottle but um you know each so let's just kind of back up to those studies in that study
in prostate cancer the men were given 60 milligrams per day and that that had a really positive response
so again thinking about that hermetic zone that Goldilocks zone you would each pill each one of
these these capsules has 60 milligrams in it so you really wouldn't want to do four or five I mean
there wouldn't I don't think there'd be a whole lot of the zone is probably somewhere around one or two
I would say you're experimenting with men there so women would be less wouldn't
not necessarily because we're looking at genetics we're looking at absorption and men versus women on
absorption there's probably no difference but I guess a weight-based assessment um that could come
into play but I think just in general around 60 around one to two caps per day just see you're putting
that product into the syringe diluting it and put it in syringe and using it that way right okay
right so I'll link that article on how um on why on what our thought processes on using
the the rectal veins and um and bypassing the stomach so you can kind of have a um a reference too
because it does it has higher bioavailability and you know if we're looking at cancer we just want
we want to double triple check and I will say this is that I'm going to be doing a a zoom call on the
time restricted eating and that so that's basically where we're eating in a window of about around seven
hours and what that gives our body a chance to do is heal our gut you know make sure our liver gets a
break and when you're looking at if you're doing the time restricted eating and there's a link to the
article on the Facebook page it's really hard sometimes to get your supplements in so using the
rectal delivery actually complements that and I I put that in the article that I'll be posting if
that doesn't um that doesn't make sense at all I'll post it in there and kind of our thought process
on why we're coupling the two together okay guys do you have any other questions
so I'm going to wrap it up here and okay so next week Dr. Conner's will be back and I'm sure he will
have a very exciting topic to talk to us about and answer some of the questions in the meantime again
um look for all the stuff I talked about to be posted on the Facebook page and also the zoom question
that was um that came in last night about the pros and cons of surgery and biopsies when you have cancer
we're going to be uh addressing that as well so um thank you guys for tuning in and it was a
pleasure and I will see you guys later are you the doctor that's opening the Florida office
I am that is me so this is my fourth year with the Conner's clinic so it's time for us to fly south
well then sometimes we can make a vacation out of our appointments you sir can you sir can we
last year we can't vacation in Minneapolis but right have a good imagination we just
hop here in in January but yeah we're really excited um we're we're in the early stages right now
but hopefully we're opening it up at the summer and keep on praying for us and um we're just
excited that we're expanding so um it a lot of blood insurance yeah right I know I know we're
looking at and landing so all right guys well thank you I think pleasure okay talk to later thanks
thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you